the hypocritical part about it is that
we make fun of girls all the time for
not controlling their shoulders and
being opposed all the time like she
belongs to the streets all this stuff
you tell guys that they're losers if
they don't go to the gym they're losers
they play video games you're a loser if
you smoke weed you're a loser if you
watch sports you need to exercise
discipline but when it comes to girls oh
[__] get a vasectomy because you can't
control yourself because you're not
capable of exercising discipline why you
have to be disciplined in every single
aspect of life networking success all
this stuff watching sports playing video
games you need to be on your stuff but
for women nut inside girls with after
getting a transgender surgery
we didn't
red pills imploding very quickly
recently you saw Andrew Tate or Tate
calling red pillars autistic and be like
don't ever associate me with those
losers the men who are out here only
trying to have sex with women and have
no emotional connection they're weirdos
a lot of this red pill how to get girl
stuff a lot of them are like that as
well they're like the peak masculine
life it's just I have a bunch of women
that you barely know and that's stupid
that's [__] ridiculous and that's a
supreme leader leader pill
um and you're seeing a lot of people
kind of abandoning ship and so snico saw
something recently and it kind of caught
his attention let's listen said
something yesterday on Twitter saying
that men should get vasectomies in their
20s just let me prevent this if you
don't know he's talking about he's
talking about Rolo tomasi uh he is the
grand wizard of the red pill Community
um he's supposedly the Creator he's
written books on it basically some old
geezer so he said that people should get
vasectomies if they want to be high
value men very quickly
when they're young they should get
vasectomies now quick information on
vasectomies while they are quote unquote
reversible how reversible they are is
based on the length of time that you've
had to respect me if you go past five
years the odds can drop anywhere from 90
to
30 to 40 percent
and even then after you reverse it being
fertile we don't know when it comes back
and so essentially when doctors allow
you to get a vasectomy they're telling
you this is not reversible so you need
to be certain that you don't want kids
anymore you should not think of it as a
form of birth control that you can
really nearly come in and out of
that's why a lot of doctors if you're
below the age of 25 will not even
consider you for vasectomy because they
understand how life-changing it is and
though you may not want kids as a young
man they know you might change your mind
so
quick little information about
vasectomies there you go I think that
it's important to to have family values
and to and to prepare for eventual
Parenthood why what makes you high value
other people's perception having a lot
of money having a network like why does
that matter why does being a high value
man matter if you're not going to
eventually start a family to be a high
value man the top three steps avoid
family creation get a vasectomy and have
a network it's just like the generic
mail some improvement stuff but num like
two of the top three get a vasectomy and
avoid family creation do you agree
when he says high volume and he's
talking from the perspective of being
able to be a playboy and get as many
girls but why is that a priority over
having a fat like why would that even be
advice why would that be a male
self-improvement advice
not be a playboy instead of raise a
family well we we like we make fun of
women all days who wanted to be girl
boss Queens to sleep around and have all
this and then you tell guys be a playboy
instead of raise a family that's the
same advice on the other side
what oh my nothing to say
I was just like yeah go home
go
low-key
I did laugh a few times when I was
watching this
yeah which I understand wait why well
because it's you adding a sneak or
talking
so the only thing you hear is
so yeah
no that's where you laugh you're
laughing right now
so I know that's you that's not I laugh
that's you laughing I'm gonna I'm gonna
play with you guys you're gonna play
with us
hey yo the most joyous moments of my
life were coming home and then seeing
all my kids around and then getting
spend time with them and that divorce
going through that whole process that
really stole for me like what I realized
is my biggest choice
I spend time with my nieces now I spend
time with my mom taking her out to
dinner you know showing her good stuff
and I realize like that's that's the
stuff that matters for me
I've had if I get new one is not even
but when I spend time with my niece and
I'm watching her like walk for the first
time or I'm seeing her say words like
that [__] hits different so you're
giving up on your balls yeah you're
getting older like that's just like I'm
too tired of fun that sounds boring I
don't want to be when I'm 32 I want to
be [__] double the [__] I'm
[__] now I want to be having a bigger
house having like I want to be down to
Hugh Hefner [__] that's what makes you
excited that's what keeps your balls
going like you can't let go of that you
can't let go of your manhood at a
certain age if you give up on that like
oh I like playing macaroni drawings with
my kids you trying to say something he
was just smiling you but I was a young
him you understand what I'm saying I was
him nine months ago
this just makes me laugh how drastic the
changes in rhetoric where it's like now
he sounds like a Ben Shapiro clone but
look
I'm not mad at it because what he's
saying is true so at the end of the day
it's a change genuine whatever who knows
I don't know I'm not gonna get
somebody's hit doesn't matter people are
encouraging people to be more Community
oriented and think more about things
that important in life I support that
kind of messaging well we we make fun of
women all days who wanted to be girl
boss Queens to sleep around and have all
this and then you tell guys be a playboy
instead of raise a family that's the
same advice on the other side because
here's the thing when you're a Playboy
you're gonna be better at raising the
family
being a Playboy makes you better at
raising a family no you said the family
which
Don which family are we talking about
because Playboys tend to have multiple
families and I'm going to tell you those
kids don't look at that dad and think
wow what a wonderful guy I ask a lot of
women or Sons or men what it was like to
have a dad who's a womanizer
who's out here sleeping around doing
left to right center they don't
necessarily speak about those people in
glowing colors they don't be like oh he
was really present in my life he was
really invested
oh yeah the way he treated my mom and
how happy she was everything was fit
yeah it's fine to want to go do your
Hedonism and [__] left right and center
but don't pretend like it's actually
helping families
and the reason but he's saying avoid
family creation well he's saying he's
talking from the frame of being a guy
getting a lot of girls
and then if you want to decide you want
to get a family down the road you can
always unsnip and then go ahead and go
down the family route I agree to a
degree that you need to have sex with at
least 50 girls as a guy I've talked
about that all the time it's
controversial at this point in your
career when you're on the way up focus
on things that are going to help you
move forward in life and become
successful get a surgery done that
prevents you from having children yeah
we can always reverse it because it's
not like a lot of the times that should
mess us up it's that's not something you
could just like hope that it's going to
be okay generally most men can't control
their urges so what's gonna happen it's
gonna go [__] around and get somebody
pregnant becoming good Fathers too just
like we make fun of girls for
prioritizing their careers and wanting
to be girl bosses and wanting to build
an Empire they're not prioritizing
motherhood immediately and then we're
saying men ignore family creation get a
vasectomy so you could focus on getting
rich and then you'll be 40 you'll have
all these uh all these girls and girls
and then start a family like how are we
building men to become good Fathers if
they've been only prioritizing success
if they have a dick surgery how do they
have the character that's going to lead
a proper family so you're seeing because
I've dealt with a bunch of hoes first so
they know what a good one is so you're
I dealt with a bunch of hoes first and I
know what a good woman is
not even know what a bunch of holes is
I just wonder all the guys out there who
married women who weren't hoes or
whatever the [__] it is do you think
they have a bunch of hoes to find that
up well everybody was in a relationship
right now had to find some dirty broads
to realize like oh
I now know what a decent person who's
capable of being a wife is yeah yeah I
had to [__] all these STD ridden horse
to find that out
I did
I have to go to the club and find the
easiest sloppiest drunkest
loser to be like
hey I know I just got done busted inside
you but I think I realized
you shouldn't be the mother of my kids I
think I'm red I think I do that 49 more
times apparently no no no no
say that you know so no but what's the
priority then not only are this doesn't
mean that you need to have kids young
but it shouldn't be avoid family
Creation in your head that's an
important thing to think about when
you're young too how am I going to be
how am I going to have the character how
am I going to have the maturity the
responsibility to become a good father
when I am ready to do it I'm telling
guys you should get rich as possible too
but you should also be working on like
building your character and looking at
how I'm gonna raise my kids and how I'm
gonna be a good father if you're 40 and
you have all these hoes and you have you
have experience with those is that going
to make you a better father probably not
you'll just know how to avoid a bad
woman but it's not that you don't need a
hundred women to realize what a hoe is
why not just avoid why not just
understand that a lot of these women are
unwifable and then navigate around that
instead and just not spend your time and
invest your energy into women that you
don't even respect your life I was like
he was just looking at all the women on
the podcast but something like like
these [__] why would you constantly
invite
these soulless most vapid Instagram
hungry
go but I just say this sneaker is
preaching
no pun intended and everything there is
making sense it's like you think you're
going to be a player your whole life and
then all of a sudden you're capable of
doing a committed relationship like
trust me most the players I know who did
that for a long time struggled
tremendously trying to settle down
tremendously trying to settle down and
so all of us thinking like you got the
skills for long-term relationships and
you can figure it all out it's gonna be
easy because you've been [__] this
whole time like what you do to be able
to get women to sleep with you it's not
the same thing as what you do in order
to get a woman to stay with you through
a long-term relationship those things
are completely different things you're
talking about different but you'll
notice that when these guys talk about
maintaining a relationship all of their
language is geared on how to get a woman
to give you sex and pretty much and
often time
what makes you gonna get a girl in the
clubs and stuff like that like the way
these guys want to get girls
it's actually not attributes that people
are looking for to form a family
that's not what they're looking for
that's not what
what's attractive
in a family setting they don't care
about that so none of these attributes
are going to be like yeah he's able to
get a lot of girls
that's not all they want to get with
just always brought to you by surf shark
no matter where I'm at all right whether
it's uh in my house or in my Airbnb one
on my way or in Antarctica
or or even when I'm taking a [__] I need
to have access to all my programs hey
but sometimes the internet doesn't allow
me for that because it's restricted
because of the area that I'm in
yeah and for that I need a system that
allows me to change my location
and that's called a VPN changer yes in a
wonderful VPN that I'm using is surf
shark and it allows you to just change
the location of where you are and you
can watch everything that you want no
matter where you're at right now with
Thrift Shop you can just use promo code
Abba and preach and you're gonna be able
to have three months extra free
I know crazy
get on it so this was a sweet right it
goes um and this was from what a week
ago about a week one week ago so the
quickest path the quickest path to
becoming a high value man number one
don't get married avoid family creation
vasectomy in your 20s life uh lift
consistently eliminate all sedations
learn game and networking play tier
strengths build wealth resist easing up
on your focus and it's uh the quickest
path to becoming a high value man
um and I know that you know snico had
some point of contention specifically
with number three which is get a
vasectomy in your 20s what is high value
men
I think he means what he means in this
context is getting being a guy that's
like desirable to women and being money
being attractive to women so that you'll
be uh I guess a marketable sexual party
but that doesn't make sense right like
avoid family creation and get a visit we
attracted to men but well no no
again like I said it before I'll say it
again because you're here given the
context of what he's tweeting for this
specific situation it makes sense
because he's saying hey these are the
ways so that you don't [__] yourself up
to ensure that you're going to be
successful he's [__] proofing it but
that is a pretty [__] advice because
you're saying do this so that you become
more attractive to women so what's even
the point of having a relationship with
a woman if you can't have kids with her
then you're just having an empty
relationship just a [__] her for your
whole life and no he's saying to become
high value which means you made the
choice do you want to do that or not so
he's giving a choice to do that don't
you guys tweet all the time about how
like oh like women are [__]
disgusting that are freezing their eggs
at like 20 and they're gonna find out I
know you've got like guys that go to
sperm clinics like here you go I'm never
gonna be able to pregnant my wife
because it's like a 30 reversal rate on
this [__] surgery but
yeah but you can do it but when you're
28 29
.
yo [__] I'm asleep
you know what this man thinks he thinks
as long as you don't hit their 10-year
Mark [__] you made it no it's not like
the surgery works man it's not like you
get to 10 years all of a sudden now you
can't slip your balls anymore because oh
my God what's expiry date on my dick
that's not how it works is that from
zero to ten years it gradually reduces
the odds of you being reserves so the
longer it goes on the less fertility you
have it's not like I got the eight years
okay I made it before no that's not how
it works
so instead of it being a 30 chance maybe
it's a 45 or 50 at eight years you don't
know all these things are variables so
you the question is
if your audience is looking at this and
you're supposed to tell them okay guys
get a vasectomy so you'll be a high
value man you should also tell them if
you go through this vasectomy there's a
50 chance that you may not be able to
ever have kids again
is that something you're
you're risk yo these [__] are
never gonna do that [__] they talking
that [__] then when they would never do
that one two would you cross the street
if you have 45 chance of making it alive
the other side
45 chances
he's gonna have kids
I was nervous there for a second and
that was a coin
so nine years what is it 45 chance of
reversal bro you're not gonna have kids
anymore you're sterilizing half your
audience
he had two points there he said one
avoid what family creation and three so
that's gonna be twenties you can choose
what you want to do you know play what
you need to apply he just saying you
could do either work
it's funny when I go to the groceries my
girl gives me a list and she's like she
wanted the ginger and she wanted
broccoli and she really meant either or
no she meant both [__] it's a lit it's a
little brother
it's a list
yo bash it though on the loose it said
lift consistently is that also an option
he's just I get it though at the end of
the day I think Road tomasi for them is
a friend of the show and they want to
defend them but even if they sound
irrational right which they always
critique women for being it doesn't
really matter because they're being
loyal so as long as you sound neurotic
for your friends it's acceptable yeah
exactly on that list he's got two things
okay about your dick okay about avoid
family creation gonna protect me is
there anything on the list about like
just avoid women but holy Temptation
hold on hold on we know as men we want
women no matter what but whether we want
to abstain or be more it doesn't matter
however question for you guys on the
panel if you have a kid be honest here
would you be where you are right now
Destiny had a kid no no no well oh you
did yeah his early 20s I don't know why
not just like use protection yeah see
this okay that's a good point and he's
and he said avoid what is Christian
which means he's a condom too no it
doesn't it says get a vasectomy that was
the enough
number three number two says avoid what
the hypocritical part about it is that
we make fun of girls all the time for
not controlling their sexual urges and
being hoes all the time like she belongs
to the streets all this stuff you tell
guys that they're losers if they don't
go to the gym they're losers they play
video games you're a loser if you smoke
weed you're a loser if you watch sports
you need to exercise discipline but when
it comes to girls oh [__] get a
vasectomy because you can't control
yourself because you're not capable of
exercising discipline why you have to be
disciplined in every single aspect of
life networking success all this stuff
watching sports playing video games you
need to be on your stuff but for women
nut inside girls with after getting a
transgender surgery
see we didn't we didn't we didn't quite
lose sneako there we didn't quite lose
him he's still there still they're still
there it's he's still there that's funny
he said you see we don't we heard what
he said we heard what she we heard we
heard what he said
[__] that's the one thing you can't be
disciplined stay cool put it number two
say avoid from a creation it could be
Cardinal or Plan B but you just saying
to be extra form of contraception is
what it is basically well he didn't say
that and that's that's not a good form
of contraception because it's not
supposed to be reversed that's what the
doctor tells you when you get a
vasectomy surgery it's like you cannot
expect this to be reversed that's not
that you shouldn't go into that thinking
that you're gonna reverse it and also
the better advice instead of saying
never [__] again maybe for the women
that I do have sex with prepare that she
could be the mother of your children
maybe don't spend time with hoes all the
time thinking I need to [__] 50 girls so
I understand feminists and how [__]
they are maybe just don't [__] them
maybe [__] women that you can see
yourself having a family with when you
first you won't be able to detect that
though exactly you need experience you
need experience bro wait no no how do
you need experience what does that mean
how would you know what's good for you
if you never had it
do you think you need to [__] a girl to
tell if she's like family material no no
no we're saying experience wise what is
experience now dating courting and
having that one-on-one experience okay
she's like a station doesn't like this
this is weird this doesn't work I can
tell from experience what works
I'm getting there okay now adding in sex
you can understand okay once this past
this point has passed I can see which
really is because remember people put on
our front at the very beginning
thank you
yo yo
other than sex
there's some things that are more
telling of who the person really is okay
one watch who they are when they drive
two
try to put a Ikea uh Furniture together
three
go on a trip with that person that's how
you see how really someone is four go to
a restaurant see how they treat someone
that they have power over and can do
nothing for them there's other things in
life more than [__]
okay that you're gonna be able to do
that's gonna be tell signs
of what the person is as a matter of
fact I can tell you
a lot of people I've seen in toxic
relationship will stand because the
[__] or the dick was good
um
I had nothing to do with how they were
because how they were was really garbage
was trash
mm-hmm
they were garbage human beings he don't
like when I say that I'm gonna tell you
I know them people garbage human beings
but the people stay because the sex was
good so the sex thing really is
something on the side it doesn't tell
you how the person is
I'll go a step further oh go ahead step
on I don't think sex tells you much
about a woman
I think it does tell you something about
a man though
because the people who I see switch up
after sex are generally dudes
because yes once they get the women
right now I know they're in the comments
okay yes
you wanna know why because I've changed
you changed it up and women always
complain everything was great then we
slept together I was like Yay because
sometimes they only in it for that
so I'm just saying generally the women
with ends up happening is that they just
become more into that's it
that's really it yup I I'll be honest
with you I've talked to a lot of guys
and all they ever say after sex with
women was like she became more attached
that's it I have nothing to do with
right now she's watching material or
marriage material it's just that
Grandma but ass ladies ass ladies ladies
have definitely sat with a dude that
noticed his behavior changed afterwards
and boy became more distant or he
stopped responding to calls all of a
sudden so no I think the reality is
they're framing this is like oh you need
to bang her to really see who she is
that is one of the dumbest ways to get
to know something you want to know
you're gonna have to spend some time
observing her in all the areas even when
you live together you're gonna learn who
that person really before you live
together go on a trip together plan some
things together see how you communicate
with each other that's how you is and
after that from whenever things go bad
see how you're gonna grow from that and
make it not happen again
that's what you're gonna see [__]
ain't gonna be the one but
yeah sure experience as you say uh let's
go let's go ugh mind you
Myron's never been in a relationship
how many stories do you hear of husbands
who are like my wife used to blow me
every single day and then assistant got
married all the sex stuff or we you know
we have dead bedrooms now we were super
active our first year but that is
absolutely not true what no he pretty
he's saying the [__] yeah yeah she
preaching you preach it she
I don't even know just because I I don't
like the idea of a man just denying a
woman her her new credit so just let it
happen okay
you're telling me you have to throw like
30 women to find like how many
conservative men like if we run in like
real conservative men who have strong
Families how many they're like yeah you
know I had to [__] 25 [__] when I was
in college or refined the love of my
life right now they can take care of my
kids that's a wild statement if you want
to [__] that's fine but don't pretend
you're doing it for this [__]
altruistic purpose of finding a good mom
and I also want you guys to appreciate
y'all notice these red pill dudes say
all this goofy [__] but none of them
seem to have stable families or
marriages
you know I mean like that's major Jordan
don't seem to have their [__] together
oh when they do it's always what they're
preaching against
is it like what if she throws it back
doggy she'd probably take the kids like
out to the park every day like what does
that even mean like so this is why okay
there's a bunch of reasons why I tell
guys they need to get sexual experience
with women number one you need to get an
abundance mindset okay a lot of guys get
with girls out of necessity and a
scarcity mindset first girl that touches
their pee pee Oh I want to commit to you
so that's a problem because you're not
going ahead and getting with the girl
from a position of choice you're getting
whether from a position of necessity and
scarcity that completely changes the
Dynamics of the relationship and that's
going to put her in the leverage
position that's number one number two
what do you think about this whole
leverage thing
that's whack guess what what do you
think about it a leverage that's not
that's not a relationship
that's not the definition of a
relationship that's just [__] there's
there's one side of this lacking like
this I gotta have this level you're
calculating leverage and what grade are
we in [__] Junior High what do you
mean the leverage this [__] that we I
see [__] that we used to do yo don't
call them now call them later cause you
need to think that that's some [__] that
we used to do back then with one Junior
High that's what this [__] was that's
what this [__] is
but that's what this [__] is that's some
High School Musical [__] you know what
you cannot call them now because now
it's gonna mean that you're too much and
that that's that that's that [__] and
now you're gonna you're gonna you're
gonna you're gonna keep doing that [__]
as an adult
uh B and nobody got time like that like
for real when you realize at some age
people ain't got time like people don't
have that time people don't really have
to have a leverage I she I gotta care I
gotta care she I gotta care less than
she does cause then I'm gonna have
leverage and I'm gonna have power man
I'm just curious guys oh I'm just
curious guys if you heard the girl that
you were interested talking like that I
gotta have leverage over him how would
you guys feel and would you guys
maintain interest vice versa ladies if
you heard that a man wanted to maintain
leverage over you and he had to care
less how would you guys feel I'm
actually curious what you were so again
bro
that's exactly what the context right
you're taking you're taking it you're
taking what he's saying and like
applying it to the general Masters he's
saying in this specific instance high
value you want to get get your value up
as quickly as possible who is that
advice for young men not the guy who's
already had three kids who's 36 he's not
gonna decide I'm gonna become a high
value man like after having a family
you're targeting towards young men who
navigating life taking advice from an
older guy on the internet so Monday uh
okay so this next part is when the guy
who made that tweet comes in I say we
stopped here and we cover this a
difference sure
all right let us know what you guys
think